good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Thursday September 12th we're
almost there we are crawling anger
towards weekend to us it feels like
Friday though because we are headed to
Austin after this show we will have a
podcast episode for you tomorrow from
Austin I'm actually travelling to the
show obviously like I can't stay away
from the dirty jeans tour but I'm really
coming to like do our podcast together
which is really a new thing for us I
know like traveling together
well yeah but taking this show on the
road it's only really because we're
going to Austin like if we were going to
like Poughkeepsie you wouldn't be coming
I don't know if C is beautiful this time
of year
it really is it's really you can't
stress that enough no when I've actually
been to Austin a good amount I'm really
feelin remiss that I didn't make it to
Charlotte Charleston and a couple of the
Canadian states yeah well speaking of
Canadian states I'm heading to Vancouver
ticket sale about girl [ __ ] calm the
end of this month also in the few months
San Diego San Francisco Seattle Portland
Vancouver Los Angeles head over girl
with no job comm Philly Pittsburgh
Toronto their souls show they're sold
out but um yeah head over to girl with
no shop comm shows fun it's great good
time happiness GA tickets start at like
$35 like very reasonable I think so it's
pretty well we are obviously going to
deliver the Fast Five stories that you
need to know before you wake up day by
day I'm writing toast are we also going
to be recapping Real Housewives of
Dallas Real Housewives of Orange County
because I can only watch so much because
I went and I saw Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood last night I was supposed to
see good boys but then we were sitting
in the theater and I was like being
annoying today I was like I wish we were
seeing one spot and tiny'mon in
Hollywood but thanks for planning its
date night wait you left good boy he
hadn't started and then so we quickly
looked up what time once upon a time in
Hollywood was playing and I was paying
50 in 15 minutes so we like got out of
the theater we changed our tickets and
we went to see a good film that is such
a weird thing I know but like we both
realize that's what we wanted to be
seeing and movie hadn't started yet so
we were like let's go but you walked out
on Jacob Tremblay I'm telling his
parents I did walk out on Jacob Tremblay
but like he'll be around for longer it
came out more recent
once upon a time in Hollywood is on its
way out it's something I wanted to see
on the big screen it's also a mouthful
to say well the bottle um and I really
really enjoyed it like it was so long
which is why I could only watch one show
last night got it um but the end just
made the whole movie wonderful and I
realized like that's Quentin Tarantino's
thing I'm not much of a film buff but
that's his thing to like you know take
real historic moments and then change
them the way he would like to see I
think it's like such I know people think
he's crazy I just think it's like a
genius premise like the movie
inglourious basterds it's like the only
Holocaust movie where I don't cry
because the Nazis burned down in flames
and it's like you have a pic because you
know how any like history we know how it
ends in and you just have a pin it's
like oh my god Sharon Tate's pregnant
like she's about to die and then he just
puts his own spin on it and it was
really enjoyable and in the rest of the
movie is like long and slow but I think
like for movie people which I'm not one
of it's just enjoyable it harks back to
the 60s old hollywood and like it's
really well done and i just thought it
was an enjoyable flick um I don't know
what people said about it because like I
said I'm not gonna change very much
enjoyed it um it was really just
enjoyable
everyone was so good looking well now we
can send heads together then week I
really want to see either said a weird
thing till I go to Austin and like go to
the movies no I don't think so let's
just say yeah um yeah what do you think
factor dad oh sorry you guys I meant to
tell you got upgraded your first class
on the flight so I'll just like see you
guys later
so it's the story of our lives not a new
thing I guess we'll just have to sit
together so - I guess we'll just have to
like have my meal in first class the
glass of shampoo I mean so sad
hate to see how men they see me in this
outfit though upgrade me thank you guys
I wish it works that way ya know based
on like merit not meritocracy ah paste
on like finances yes based on like who's
company pays for them to travel the most
you know it should also be like you know
when people are walking onto the plane
they see the people in first class it's
really like a reflection of the brand
yeah and I think I'm a good brand
ambassador because it's like your anger
blaze I'm wearing a blazer but also like
casual I'm not like why is she wearing
them you're not trying too hard like Pan
Am style like I remember like alongs to
the days of Pan Am but can we just talk
about how like people were trying so
hard back then like it's on a plane
you're on a plane she wearing heels on
the plane but it was exciting like
you're in the sky no and I see that
and I understand that but there's also
like an element of looser enos about it
no I don't think so I think we're looser
we're bigger
we've never been bigger losers than we
are today how's the society like I
literally brought a juicy tracksuit to
change into so I can be a slob on the
plane I understand for a bit I wore this
disgusting
that would be discussing if I wear this
you know it's also disgusting people who
wear shorts on plane it's like all of
your skin just like touching the plane
Ben wear shorts almost every time we fly
no matter where we're going and no part
of me doesn't think it's disgusting
okay Bay I will give our husbands a pass
for wearing shorts on a plane because
like they get hot you know so but but
you know I won't often freezing hot
isn't acceptable skirts on a plane oh by
the way I've literally never seen I
don't even know one time when I was
younger and they funny what sticks with
you and by the way it's hilarious what's
tickle arias what sticks with you I it
was a miniature face like Mean Girls era
and I was like loving wearing mini skirt
and we were going to Florida and I asked
mom if I could wear a skirt on the plane
and she was like no and ever since then
like I've I've acted right and they
would never wear a skirt they would
never even can you guys feel like a
little 12 year old with a miniskirt on
the plane you would never even cross my
mind to like pull a skirt out for the
plane I mean I think it's important for
everyone oh I don't own any skirts like
actually no I I literally do not own a
single skirt yeah that's that tracks
just like you guys are freaks but like
you most people like have skirts in
their closets yes most people have
skirts like for one reason like a
conference conference skirts you know
you uh gue you're going out skirt a
church skirt Yeshua temple skirt yeah I
can only go for one of those like locked
to the floor skirts on a plane that's
probably really comfortable yeah but
it's like just stick with leggings yeah
they love me some leggings they won't
fail you okay so do you do you think
it's doing anything I think it's fun cuz
we actually have a flight to catch so
aegis time it better be time for the
fast facts story is that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast this episode
of the morning toast I've decided not to
be annoying and just let you know that
it's brought to you by modern fertility
you've probably thought about the next
step in your career in your relationship
but what about planning for a baby women
are having children later in life but
biology hasn't changed and we need tools
to understand the future of our
fertility if you want more information
about your
to get pregnant you need modern
fertility it's a quick and easy hormone
test you can take at home whether you're
thinking of trying for a baby now or you
want to know your options for the future
your results are delivered within 10
days and your personalized dashboard
will give you an insight into how many
eggs you have hormone levels and any
reproductive red flags you can also talk
one-on-one with a fertility nurse and
use a time line tool to plan ahead
proactive testing through your doctor
can cost over a thousand dollars but
with modern fertility you can get the
same information for just one hundred
and fifty nine dollars and right now
mono fertility is offering our listeners
$20 off the test when you go to modern
fertility calm / toast that's $20 off
your fertility test when you go to
modern fertility dot-com / toast modern
fertility calm / toasts sign on and
gobbling get burnished em so funny I was
talking actually with my friends at
wedding this weekend how when the way
you talk about like getting pregnant
when you're younger versus when like
you're actually trying it's on the
horizon like every time you talk about
it you're like brother like you know
with the fruits if the gods smiled down
upon me I was even talking about it with
my non-jewish friends and like the way
like their phrases cuz I always say like
broccoli shopping like things in Hebrew
but they were like if the Lord sees it
just it was so funny who he started to
sound like carry out of handmaids tell
ya if it should bear fruit Lebanon shall
be plentiful finished I'll be plentiful
and we shall multiply
i'ma shall bear fruits of our loins I
mean I tell you it's a practice every
statement if ya kid because like you're
so superstitious
yeah just funny are you superstitious
like about I mean like do you do weird
things who I'm superstitious about
saying things before they are but if you
walk under a ladder no I'm not super oh
I wouldn't walk under a ladder just for
safety reasons not superstition if
someone crosses over me and that's fine
it lasts pill salt
goodbye I always throw salt I know but
then you're like just getting more salt
on the floor I never liked that
someone's job to clean it up so I just
do very little um Friday the 13th black
cat tomorrow is actually Friday before
13th spooky stuff also I was planning I
had like a big tour meeting this weekend
we were like planning shows and stuff
and I was showing Friday the 13th
[Music]
hmm Omar oh yeah that's your show oh but
then I've to spooky stuff Friday the
13th and also Colgate Day which gives it
a much more positive spin I also won't
sit on the corner of a table actually
now I will but if you're a single girl
you shouldn't sit on the corner of a
table you'll never get married but like
I put my purse on the floor even though
they say that you're all your money's
gonna fall out I know but it's also like
where the else [ __ ] am I supposed to put
it right
look those curvy chairs that don't have
any [ __ ] like hooks for your bag
restaurants that have those hooks that
they put on the table for literally for
your purse like are living in a
different time period like it's they're
so futuristic they're so futuristic like
they're so like female forward and I
think Hasbro could take a page out of
their book that was so funny
yesterday's show was hilarious it
totally looks for story um the first
stories a bit of good news the stitch
has been released from prison after
eight months not to be confused with the
snitch because she did not go to prison
about eight not yet flew by flew but is
he already out yep the stitch is a free
man a news can confirm the Jersey Shore
star was released from prison in
Otisville New York on Thursday morning
Sorrentino wife Lauren Pesci accompanied
him as he made his long-awaited
departure from the federal correction
facility well we are elated to finally
close this chapter of our life thank you
to our family friends and fans for the
continuous love and support during this
time it brought us so much peace and
comfort we look forward to continuing
our life as husband and wife and working
on baby situations baraka shem if the
Lord willed that if your first of your
labor shall bear fruit we truly believe
that the comeback is always greater than
the setback agreed and we can't wait to
show the world ours wow that is so great
I know like it probably didn't feel like
that for him but like it really just
flew by yeah like when we reported that
action to jail yeah and now it's nine
months later wow that's so crazy I
wonder if he has any stories I would
love to talk to I'm sure he was hanging
out Billy McFarland yes I this must be
such a relief
you know like I'm sure it's a relief
when you finally I get the sentence and
go to prison just like start get on your
way but now this is all behind him like
he's a new man and like the Jersey Shore
family reunion vacation show is still on
so like he has a career waiting for him
yes stands waiting for him and why and
it just open road like where is the past
years have been he's been so bummed down
by lately but he just go out and have
fun but he knows in the back of his mind
he's probably like president next year
yeah and like he just the weight of the
world was on his shoulders I think he's
gonna be a totally new man me too I
think he's really close to reaching Pete
John status like there's something
really like sad and cute about him and
even in the one season of Jersey Shore
family reunion that he was on he was
just like sober and like trying to like
still hang out with everyone like go to
the club and I just think there's a real
precious gem potential there I agree and
like in this situation I would be here
for a situation Pesci reality show and I
would watch it just because like I want
this to be successful yeah yeah I don't
know that i would like but i just want
whatever shows gonna make him the most
success that probably is Jersey Shore
like I actually think I spin off like
just wouldn't do well cuz nobody watches
TV anymore apparently
yeah you know but all in all this is
just a great day and it's like a
Thursday you know what a great day to
get out of jail yeah you have the
weekend ahead of you like all your
friends and family who are working like
they'll be able to come see like you
don't to wait like if it's Monday you
have to wait till Friday to see everyone
you know yeah it's gonna have a nice day
with his wife and the tomorrow probably
big family Italian dinner totally what
do you think he's gonna eat okay let's
say you're in Princeton for eight months
which in the grand scheme of like prison
sentences is in a long time but like
eight months sitting in a Cell is a very
long time you get out like what are you
meeting um I think I'm having pizza
pasta meet you but like are you having
it like he's Italian so are you gonna
have it like homemade or like no I would
HIGHLY be like Serafina or maybe
Scarpetta if I was feeling fancy yeah
and would you go out or would you eat in
your house I would probably want to eat
in my house like I never want to go out
again
um because I would just be so happy to
be home so I probably order in so you'd
make like your dominant Dominus Domino's
you know I would order like actually I
wouldn't make then go out and get like
really good
then cross New York Pizza yeah yeah
penne alla vodka spaghetti Pomodoro
fountain soda
garlic knots but then also when you're
in prison like I feel like people really
get in shape and they start to take care
of themselves and so like maybe he's now
like a clean eating situation that's
actually a really good point and now I'm
sad cuz knowing he probably won't have a
good meal ya know because he loves to
eat but I think he's definitely I mean I
haven't seen photos but he's probably
lost weight in prison because like
that's what people do yeah I don't think
there's
like an abundance of food in prison like
even if you're not trying to lose weight
I think you just do yeah it's like
summer camp I think there's a canteen
and like you can not call the canteen
it's called the commissary my god like
do you even one charge is the new black
now I'm it's called a commissary and
yeah like you can buy but you make like
I don't understand how it works like I
think like your family can put money in
your account or like the work that you'd
like you have a job in prison like that
money also but it's like expensive I
think it's it depends based on the
prison right so yeah it oranges a new
back they sell like chips and pop tarts
and like tampons yeah oh my god I just
remembered we're going on a trip and I
didn't pack any tampons you can see us
I'm from bathroom here and low low yeah
yeah also remember that game I'm going
on a picnic and I'm bringing apples yeah
that's fun game I know you love to play
it I do we'll play it later that's are
you okay snatcher I was feeling sick so
she took her microphone off as to not
because I don't want to be sniffing and
being annoying you can lay down on the
couch you don't know I'm feeling fine I
just need to sniffle so I took the mic
off I don't I mean you take a break okay
hit the couch hit the showers shout
peace out snitch cam um a bit of good
news we're just so benevolent we are
we're just like you know Isis the word
benevolent is one that pisses me off can
I tell you why first of all it sounds
confusing because it sounds like strong
words benevolent she's nice second of
all in the third grade we had a spelling
bee and I obviously got off on
benevolent yeah but also sounds like a
really strong word when the meaning of
the term is actually like pretty it's
like yeah weird benign
yes benign tumor oh no you know yeah
that's good [ __ ] I'm like oh okay
that's also like that's like a pet movie
Sasha Baron Cohen the dictator oh yeah
oh Aladin when it's you are a legate
changed the words in his country and his
name is Allah Dean so he made like a
million words mean Aladeen and positive
and negative so the guy said the doctor
he's like you are Aladeen for AIDS and
he said yeah no I love [ __ ]
that's actually had a bit what some be
called The Dictator no that's the Seth
Rogen movie
that's the interview oh yeah okay
dictator I think it's better than Borat
I think said to Borat it's great and
like iconic but it's a little out of
control like a dictator cuz your name
was meant to be like a reality TV sort
of movie yeah
but the dictators like real film you
know and the dictator is who was he
supposed to be I mean any like a Saddam
Hussein by me yes definitely that's the
extreme with like a little Kim jong-il
at the time I think yeah that no that's
definitely the I but then mixed him with
a bit of democracy democracy has hairy
armpit Allison burners that's actually I
need to buy that movie for the point
it's actually said chicken i watch it
all the time and we do you it all the
employees you absolutely must
I think it's Sasha Baron Cohen's best
work I think so too and any time we
think of such more in common I just
think if I disappointed I am that he
didn't play Freddie Mercury he won with
so interesting I'm so glad you brought
that up because I was on my YouTube app
on YouTube TV and now they're serving me
up Howard Stern content and they had a
little clip of Sacha Baron Cohen on
Howard Stern talking about why he didn't
play Freddie Mercury what he said and he
was we all like we it was known that he
had a disagreement with the band members
about what they want in the movie to be
about like obviously he wanted to be
about Freddie Mercury and the band
wanted to be about it but Freddie
Mercury laughs I mean the band after
Freddie Mercury dies and Sacha Baron
Cohen was like I should have realized in
the first meeting that it wasn't gonna
work out when they said it's a really
interesting movie because like of what
happens in the middle and Sacha Baron
Cohen's like what happens in the meal
and they were like Freddie dies oh he
was like oh it's like a Pulp Fiction
where like the end is the middle in the
middle is that sort of thing you're like
no he dies in the middle and then we
carry on as a band
oh man that it's so stupid so stupid
it's obviously not even what happened
right you should have stuck around I
don't know I think there was like Mad
beef yeah well it just would have been
really good cuz he actually looks like
him when he's not even trying look
imagine after him after hair and makeup
right right missed opportunity I like
that I it's a [ __ ] d-o-double-g
dog okay next story a bit of sad news
I just wanted to close the loop on
something because a while back we have
reported that Louie Tomlinson sister had
died suddenly and it was really sad and
confusing because like young women don't
just die but it was happening and his
mom had also just passed away yes but
finally we know the cause of death
Louie Tomlinson sister died from a quote
perfect storm of drugs and this is
really just a cautionary tale which is
what I wanted to talk about it in the
show because we have a lot of young
girls watching the show I don't know
what people do in their personal lives
but this is a sad story the sister of
former One Direction star Louie
Tomlinson died after taking quote a
perfect storm of drugs a probe into her
demise revealed this week
Felicity Tomlinson a teen was found to
have a fatal cocktail of cocaine xanax
and oxycontin in her system when she
died in March at her London apartment
it was the perfect store and said the
coroner the singers half-sister
purchased cocaine with her friend the
night before she was found dead
according to the coroner who questioned
the friend in court about the teens
final hours in which the pair did cope
with another Pat POW quote a male friend
came over and you did lines of cocaine
one or two but you've said felt unwell
unwell you saw Felicity do more lines
but you don't know how many she did the
coroner said the teen was still
breathing when her friend checked in on
her around 5:00 a.m. but was
unresponsive around noon holy [ __ ] the
popstar sibling had been taking drugs on
a regular basis to cope with her
mother's death in 2016 from leukemia
according to officials though they
weren't in her system at the time she
had used MDMA acid and cannabis in the
past so she was like a recreational drug
user yeah but also not recreational when
she's like using it to cover up pain yes
so I think that's where probably the
xanax kicks in yeah and Ozzy and this
was definitely not an intentional
overdose overdose by any means which is
why it's super scary and really sad and
really really sad oh my god that's so
terrible and like it's bad enough that
she died but now it's like there's a
whole trial like going into all the
things she did like can it can a person
just recipes yeah it's like now it's
like cocaine no but I feel like people
aren't like talking about it in like a
negative sort of way but it's really
also informative because when a young
person dies and they we never find out
why like it's scary it's like Oh any one
of us could just drop dead at any minute
tell you like you need to know what
causes these things yeah so judgment
here it's like she's 18 years old she's
like such a cute fun girl like she's her
brother's a pop star and she's doing
molly like okay but not okay because
it's fate oh yeah it's just like
Saturday judge minute it's just like
what's on judgment but it does work it's
concerned but it can't feel good for
like her friends and family that like
there's literally a whole trial going
into like they saw the trial it's just
it's a report it's a coroner's report oh
no one's on trial okay it's just like an
explanation yeah it just sucks that like
she she was a private person like her
brother was a celebrity so like if she
was just a regular girl like it wouldn't
be in the news that she does drugs you
know what I mean and now that what she's
known for yeah well it doesn't have to
be that no still very sad louis
tomlinson like is can't catch a break
yeah cuz that gives me a Bethany vibe
like bad things keep happening around
him it's really sad and she was so cute
and pretty mm-hmm
thoughts and prayers okay next I'm
excited to talk about kind of pick up
the mood here um
Rihanna shook up Fashion Week with her
empowering empowering savage ex banty
show okay this happened two days ago and
I mean II talked about it but like just
the show is being streamed for Amazon
there were no phones allowed so we don't
know so much but it still looks so
[ __ ] lit the runway show is dead or
at least that's been the message at New
York Fashion Week this season we're
fully immersive experiences have stolen
the thunder of traditional catwalk
presentations when it comes to
performance though no designer can even
begin to compete with Rihanna simply put
this is what she was born to do last
night at her savage xfinty show at
Barclays Center in Brooklyn the
Barbadian superstar reminded the world
of her breath of exceptional talents so
she had all different types of models
performers etc the clothes look amazing
the show just looks like it's gonna be
like a concert dj khaled perform ASAP
ferg migos Gigi Hadid walked
normani performed in dance like Cara
Delevingne literally an award show ya
know I heard it was incredible and then
when I was at Ezra's birthday party a
bunch of people had just come from there
and they were like
shucks and they couldn't even explain
because they have their phones like
which probably was so much more
enjoyable for the people in the audience
then when you're watching the live
stream you don't see a bunch of people
like recording you see them actually
enjoying yeah
like we don't all as a society like look
so late stupid yeah that's the thing
about Rihanna it's like we were talking
about this yesterday like I don't know I
no longer like have a need from her like
to release music just because she's
doing so good at like other stuff like I
actually feel like she was put on this
earth to be like like a Liz oh you know
what I mean like she's just empowering
women like through different mediums and
her clothing is like fab and everyone
wears and everyone loves it and honestly
she never released another album again
like I would be okay with it because I'm
still getting like Rihanna content and
what's that make me feel good about
myself I just feel like Rihanna like
like she just walks the walk yeah she
doesn't talk about what she's gonna do
she doesn't like you know hype everyone
up and just talk a lot of nonsense she
does it like she leads by example and
then in her own life but then also
emanates that for other people and I
just I love her and I'm so excited for
her to really like be so in the high
fashion world
she's a mogul now yeah she's mogul for
sure um like her looks like her style is
um incredible it's everything and it's
so like forward see like she is you
think I wonder ariana grande wants to
top it right of course and like and I
copy ariana grande so it's like I'm like
we're all really just copying Rihanna in
some way shape or form a thousand
percent and she just and it's like she
doesn't she's not petty about it she
just does her thing she is on another
level and she knows that she doesn't
like get down in the nitty-gritty and
like start [ __ ] like beef between
like celebrity like she actually
empowers women she invites everyone to
her show and I just I stand no and my
favorite thing about Rihanna I remember
I saw like a meme or whatever when
everything was going down with a Taylor
Swift Kanye Calvin Harris and it was
like all the different songs
um famous was the controversial song and
then the song that Taylor Swift II
turned out that she sang on the Calvin
Calvin Harris song this is what you came
here
it's like Rihanna was actually on both
of those songs and it's like so removed
she is excluded from if they stayed out
of it you know like that's how that's
how like relevant yet above it she is
that's how you would say out of a
narrative one you never asked which to
be part of right but it's like she's
really at the center
but she's not in it at all and she's
just like a part of so many great pop
culture moments like when Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show was like at its
truest height and she just showed up
with those pearl sunglasses and now
she's like creating her own Victoria
Secret Fashion Show one in which I can
skip behind ya know people are comparing
this to like Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show being like you know the one we
deserve and I'm so here for that because
it is the one we deserve yeah also I had
one more thing to say about the Rihanna
of it all and that was something I can't
remember because you know the amnesia is
real and it's here and she's beautiful
so what was I gonna say I don't know oh
I was gonna say how like um also really
interesting like the whole stadium
Fashion Show thing like like how Kanye
did it yeah did we honor took a note out
of carnies booking liked it a little bit
better yeah which is oh no what I was
gonna say thank you that was just
something I like wanted to say so I
didn't sound stupid
um did we talk about on this show um
Organa Grande's big controversy with her
her wardrobe stylist yeah we talked
about the one that she was suing
forever21 for ten million dollars and
then the era yes Farrah and the one look
that was copy but then the PDS we never
talked about the bride yet about a Prada
a bunch of designers who had been
pitched for Ariana Grande's like
wardrobe for her tour actually sent the
actual pitch deck like the PDF file to
daya Prada which is like this fashion
Instagram page I like so like you know
like should show you the tape and it was
crazy how she had like a bunch of
pictures of Rihanna and then a bunch of
pictures of I could random girls from
Instagram and how some of the outfits
that she ended up with were like
literally carbon copy copies of things
that like she found on Instagram and on
Rihanna and on random models like yeah
um I don't know at first I was like oh
when you see two pictures side by side
and it's like one is similar to the next
like the scandal but when I was actually
reading all the comments and like really
nobody was here for the takedown it
didn't go anywhere no one wrote it up
like Ariana has not been canceled like a
it's called inspiration like I just
I don't understand what what like we
said there is a line that is it's a
blurry line for me personally it is not
where diet profit draws the line on
inspiration and I know what diet
products and I think that the bigger
issue was that most of the artists that
she was was pulling from are black and
she's like more often than not like
pulling from like urban culture without
ever like giving credit or like she's
doing it improperly agree and I saw that
I was like scandal like she's cancelled
and then I read the comments and people
and I feel like diet Prada stands are
always like really they're hard they're
on his or her side there woke yeah and
maybe it was just like re stands coming
in but everyone was like really about
spoken and they didn't have like cat
ears in their picture but they were
saying like this isn't taking and I
can't speak on I was just reading
everyone else's thoughts but it's like
there's no correlation here like they're
the the connection that they're trying
to draw between like re stealing from
like black culture it's just she likes
the clothes I don't know I I didn't
think I'd landed I do I definitely I
don't think it landed with her audience
but I definitely think in like pop
culture like I see what they're saying
like there's a lot about ariana grande
that I like but there's also a lot
that's a little questionable when it
comes to like you know just like the way
she looks in the way she acts and it's
if there's suddenly something weird
there that's all I'll say
and I'm not the right person to speak on
it because I'm not black but I just
wanna say there's something weird okay
that's all saying I mean my statement
earrings that's all we have to say I'm
not I'm not gonna disagree with you I
just uh it didn't like really stick I
thought no one no one cared yet no which
is weird because they're because the
world loves to cancel yeah not that I
wanted them to cancel but it wasn't even
a conversation yeah it never went and
like if you file that account you never
saw it again
it didn't get picked up yeah right it's
so weird what what the world chooses to
like pitchfork and what they don't yet
also did you see Kacey Musgraves at she
walked she walked the show so Rihanna
reciting tune out of Casey masks
respects female country artists I did
you all see Kacey Musgraves on the cover
of Harper's Bazaar looking like a
[ __ ] gazelle no I didn't oh my god
her leg is in the air like it's
everything oh my god I have to see do
you see Lady Gaga on the cover of allure
I did and
so can we talk about really quickly
since we were talking about Rihanna
Fenty we talked about house house make
up whatever it's called the Anna's new
makeup company like what are your
thoughts
um not for me me neither uh but I don't
think it's intended for me but do you
think it'll be successful because like
it launched in a house laboratories
that's what's called um it launched with
like a pre-sale on prime because it's a
collaboration with Amazon or something
like that I don't think it's out yet I
do think it will be successful because
like Lady gaga everything she touches
turns to success and she's being really
specific to her look and I think there's
a huge audience for that it's not me
personally I wear the same makeup that
I've been wearing since seventh grade
like the craziest thing I do is change
my lip color yes - Kylie Jenner but I
don't do like cat eye lash extensions
the whole nine yeah no um I just think
like this whole trend of like people
just like starting Beauty companies
because they think it's what they should
be doing Millie wobbly Brown is that
getting a little annoying I saw that
Millie Bobbie Brown was starting a
skincare line um and sure the Sun
children someone quoted as something
that I had said which was so profound I
didn't even know which is that her
secret to great skin is being 15 yeah I
guess it's kind of a smart business move
like to me Lady Gaga starting a makeup
company is not unique like there's
nothing different about it but Millie
bobby brown skin caroline is like
intended for children so I guess that
makes it different I don't think that
children need skin care skin care I
think you wash your face with soap and
water you go to bed like also million
Abu Brown did like a tutorial on her
Instagram story with the products and
first of all like it was so fake because
like every time she did a step should be
like okay and then she started a new
story like okay I just did that and
shake never actually did it then she put
some [ __ ] on her face like never put it
on her eyes if she was still wearing
eyeliner it was so fake I think that
bothers me yeah make at least we know
Lady Gaga like does like uses makeup
does her own makeup like I see that
Millie bobbing around in the skincare
line I'm actually annoying you know what
like more likely than not for kids like
I can't imagine it's the best quality
it's not lemare for kids right I think
it's like putting [ __ ] on their face and
that's how you break up a bone as a
child that's how you know if you do have
skincare issues like as a teenager you
go to the dermatologist and you get it
right yeah you know you get on that
accutane get on it before you can't
drink alcohol yeah totally you know
okay that was a nice tangent yeah that
was a nice tangent next story hayden
Panettiere spotted holding hands with
her ex-boyfriends brother okay this is
so weird and it reminds me of that thing
with Joe Biden's kids and that also that
thing in the Bible okay
nothing will ever be weirder than the
thing with Joe Biden's kids I couldn't
agree more except in the Bible they did
what the Bible says I agree with that so
in the Bible it says like if your
brother dies and you're a man you should
marry your brother's widow
so that she's taken care of yeah if the
widow didn't have kids right like okay
that's a sweet sentiment don't get me
wrong but we also talked about how
[ __ ] weird it is yeah it's really
weird obviously like no one really
practices that except Joe Biden's kids
except Joe Biden's kids are glad I just
remembered my dream crazier like because
they started eating like so soon after
the other one had died and then he like
they broke up and then he got married so
quick he met someone that got married
the next day and now they're being weird
still like honestly they need a reality
show
yeah Joe Biden's son really sad passed
away of like brain cancer and his wife
was dating the other brother once he
passed away and then the other brother
broke up with the wife found a
girlfriend in five minutes and now I was
married mm-hmm so strange it's so
strange I know hating past years taking
the page out of the bodies book well
they're just holding hands right but do
you hold hands with your brother-in-law
um would you ever hold Ben's hand look I
could tell you I would literally never
make sense maybe if I had a limp or I
you know right all right was like drunk
and I couldn't walk maybe maybe but I
would still probably go for like oh yeah
or like a linked arm yeah and she looks
like she's walking just fine yeah hayden
Panettiere appears to be in good spirits
after a chaotic few months with her
ex-boyfriend brian Hickerson in fact the
national star was recently spotted
holding hands with her ex's brother Zack
Hickerson in New York City honestly
they're really cute together he's super
cute according to an insider that she
walked arm-in-arm on September 4th in
the Soho neighborhood and even as
photographers captured their every move
the source said quote they continued
holding hands laughing and smiling they
looked very comfortable like a real
couple
okay the weird part is that they knew
there were cameras and they continued to
hold which might there's anything weird
about it I'm sorry like I you know I'm
it's about on the show I hated Penta
tears one of those underrated actresses
of our generation and I do not support
this it's [ __ ] weird I don't care
what the Bible says yeah no weird also
her brother the brother didn't die oh oh
right right he's still alive that just
didn't work out yeah there was like a
lot of drama between them like some
domestic violence issues like it was
really catastrophic like if I was hayden
Panettiere I might just stay away from
this family in general I don't have kids
together just like the stay away I'm
eight also but I'm gonna reserve
judgment I'm gonna give these to the
opportunity to get married and stay
together forever and then I will endorse
it well that's that's like the unwritten
rule of everything like no matter you
wouldn't cross any line you can cross
any line if the person you're crossing
the line with is your one true love
that's why I like the Jordan woods
Tristan Thompson he look wouldn't have
been terrible if they were had kids
right now you know what I mean like she
was expecting a child
uh-huh like if it was true love you
sacrificed everything like honestly it's
kind of romantic yeah but for doing it
for like some dumb you know drunk hookup
like not cute that's like Heidi and
Spencer they like turn you up everyone
everyone turn on them but they had each
other and like oh it doesn't matter and
it doesn't matter and they they're in
the right you know they come out
smelling like roses because they turned
everything down for love and what's more
noble than that that's like high school
drama where like your friends stole your
friend's boyfriend but then like if your
friends told your friend's boyfriend
they ended up getting married but you
actually did happen to someone I know
like all is forgotten yeah or like they
ended up just like dating for a long
time I'll take that to meet you like if
they can get into like a good
relationship it's like stable and happy
and brings joy for I'll give him six
months to a year I think that amount of
tear has like been through a lot and I
think that she like maybe now is like
has blurred judgment just because like I
don't think she's had a very good like
um dating life yeah history dating
history and I I feel bad cuz like I
stand you know the the raising Helen of
it all the country Nashville of it all I
just I want good thinks are gonna kind
of tear and they don't appear to be
happening no they don't but she does
look pretty happy in this picture yeah
but I feel like she always looks like
she really is her character on Nashville
like life imitates art where she goes
goes through all this stuff but she's
like such a public person and she has a
good way of hiding it but we don't even
know half of it you know yeah okay
didn't find the story a little um law
making news as the leading experts not
experts the leading commentators on the
e-cigarette trend it's our duty to let
you know that the FDA is to banish a
flavored East cigarettes to combat you
beeping okay this is actually major news
it is major news it's honestly like so
silly like because I just saw like a
million memes about it's like okay
vaping killed one person
6.now vaping killed six people there's
already a law things like guns have
literally killed people for years and no
one seems to be moving yeah I saw that
by the way it's a testament to how fast
laws can be passed I guess it's like the
way the country was built like that was
the way that's my bills are intended to
to happen it's like wow this happens so
unanimously and so fast
I'm impressed like if only this could
happen like with other more important
things yeah yeah I agree I'm sorry
vaping it's bad like you shouldn't do it
but it's not like the end OBO of our
society and people need to stop actually
like it it's because they're a bigger
problem no that's your cancer a personal
choice like I understand you don't we
want to encourage people not to but like
right you can't like I mean I guess you
can and now it's like I'm the great
analogy let's say okay it is my choice
to go into a bodega and purchase mango
jewel pods it is on my choice to go into
a bodega and try and purchase mango
jewel pods but gets shot up because
someone's there with a gun genius yeah
so I don't know I like the notion is
nice because like I think it really is
becoming an epidemic among the teens
like sure CBS has declared an epidemic
like the FDA is and it's it's
problematic yeah um but this isn't gonna
I mean is it gonna stop
teens from Julian like because really no
one would be able to get it's not like
you have to go to different states
ordering online like they won't be able
to make them anywhere it'll only maybe
they'll just jewel to back oh right well
then you're driving them maybe try like
worse options now I think it's all the
same it's just the flavor anyways not to
get political but President Trump
announced Wednesday that the
administration will move to force ISA
Guerette companies to take flavored
vaping products off the market as young
people's use of them continues to rise
and reports emerge of deaths and
illnesses tied to vaping you know what I
would like to see a study because I know
in New York they they do sell mango
jewel pods but me and Margaret will have
been to a bunch of states where you see
behind the counter like at 7-eleven they
don't have it so let me see some
statistics some facts about states that
stopped selling the
the fruit flavored pods did it make any
difference I don't know I would like to
work like it can't hurt it can't hurt
but the kids will do what kids doing
kids are always doing something and I
was watching once upon a time in
Hollywood and everyone talks about the
60s and 70s like everyone was like on
drugs and acid and had like Mert and was
murdering what stuck and that not
everyone was murdering but there's
always kids are always gonna get into
kids [ __ ] and also I feel like it's 11
love and make a wish I wish for all the
children to be happy yeah also [ __ ] what
was that gonna say Oh back in the day
when everyone was smoking cigarettes and
no one knew that they were bad for you
like the problem was you know no one
knew that they were bad but I feel like
now it's like everyone's just assuming
baking is bad even though it's
speculation because we are the guinea
pigs in it it could go either way
but meat what if at the end of the day
like it's fine actually no I guess six
people have died yeah to vaping related
I don't know I'm conflicted
no the because I'm all about personal
choice like - I want everyone to do what
they want to do when they want to do
that was like even though you know I did
I did I did partially stand my Blumberg
like I didn't think he was such a bad
mayor like in New York like look what
we're living with now like I would take
Mayor Bloomberg back at literally in ten
[ __ ] seconds I can't taking salt off
the tape see that's what I'm saying no
him taking like big sodas away like that
is where the government it's like too
much up my [ __ ] like honestly no like
it's my choice to have a soda I honestly
like I know it's not great but like this
is a free country
[ __ ] off like sometimes the government
it's like crossing a line where it's
like leave me the [ __ ] alone yeah like
you should not be in what where my salt
consumption no if salt is good enough to
be legal that it should be my discretion
you know maybe if I can't get the sauce
I'll go for something a little strong
like crack like [ __ ] off like honestly
dominoes and then see government really
pisses me off like get out of my [ __ ]
okay yeah no I agree like people should
be free to make choices both good and
bad
they think is a big problem and I think
it's really stuff the nation and we
don't have kids and we don't associate
with kids so we don't even know uh but I
don't know that this is the answer no
but I'm also like not a lawmaker they
think let there's secret secret but I
think cigarettes are disgusting like
you smoke cigarettes I think you're
literally the most vile person but you
should be allowed to buy them right I
don't think they should be illegal
that's what this was so crazy like they
give you cancer for sure and everyone
who knows who smoked cigarettes
knows that they give me bad breath
everyone who smoke cigarettes knows that
they're awful I think they're disgusting
but in no way do I think they should be
illegal because like this is a free
country like [ __ ] off that's all like
like I'm running for president Claudia
are a government get out of my [ __ ]
like that is my slogan because if that's
the truth I get it get away from me yeah
take it everywhere I go there's more
just like barriers if you want to harm
yourself like that is your choice yeah
but it's not my choice like there there
are things that like I I think should be
more restricted because like with a gun
it's like it's not my choice to get shot
right there's anyone else's tries to
shoot me and like that's where I think
the government needs to step in
yeah protected citizen yes just some
food for thought
I agree but this is really gonna like
change the game I mean even for us I
mean I am Julia I'm no longer Julie at
the end of the summer and I've been um
not really doing any more summer's over
September 21st okay they have like two
more summer weekends okay um and I
haven't really been jeweling anymore
ever since like we've been reporting
these stories but like say I wanted to
continue to willing or I couldn't stop
like I wouldn't be able to get the pods
that I like I use mint pods oh but I
thought they just had fruit flavor no
all flavors except tobacco will be
banned
that's so great it's like it actually
affects everyone who Jules totally
interesting right very so if you want
until I continue drilling you would have
to become a tobacco jewel which I would
never so maybe you have to quit I told
you I'm on the way
makes you think makes you think we're
gonna real recap Real Housewives of
Dallas but not before I tell you guys
about Skillshare it's not my learning
community with thousands of amazing
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills there's something
to be said about learning like new
traits as an adult and also it makes it
a lot easier for you to get a job if you
like our proficient in many many a class
so we've been on Skillshare for almost a
year I feel like yeah and look how
proficient we are yeah you could take
classes in everything from photography
and creative writing to design
productivity and more
I took a creative writing class and I
honestly felt like I was back like I had
my glasses on my back
you know in my living room it really um
is good for the brain just to like keep
moving yeah it is
whether you're returning to a longtime
passion project challenging yourself to
get outside your comfort zone or simply
exploring something new Skillshare its
classes for you
lifelong learning lifelong learning is
important to me honestly because I feel
like if you ever stop learning like I
feel for a while I was just like living
life without learning and my brain
stopped working and I honestly think
that's a contribution to my amnesia
definitely you can join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for our
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free so free and I'm gonna tell you
more about it but I just don't want to
choke it's okay take your time
sorry podcast listeners that's right
skill sure is offering the morning toast
listeners two months of unlimited access
to thousands of classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash morning
toast again Skillshare comm slash
morning toast to start your two months
now
that's Skillshare comm slash morning
toast sign on get smart apologize I
don't know I'm stuck having an edge you
ever want to like take a fork and
[ __ ] scratch it back your throat yeah
people are raising some interesting
points and there's one from Katy Pastore
that I would like to hear your thoughts
on this is so interesting she says how
do you feel about seat belts do you
think people should be able to not wear
one because it's illegal to not wear
your seat belt but you're only harming
yourself well if you're not wearing a
seat belt and you're in a car with other
people are you putting other people at
risk and it's technically you could fly
through and and hurt another driver like
I don't think that's why it's the law
like they're doing it for you to protect
yourself I'd be but like I'm pressin
about very interesting but if that's
like an amazing example yeah but also oh
wait no no Miran that was not gonna be a
good point no it's it's an interesting
but maybe item so it's not a blanket
statement no it is except for seat belts
like [ __ ] off okay like this like don't
try it I made a good argument don't like
come for my argument with your seat belt
[ __ ] yeah no I I'm totally in
agreement with you know and I think that
if you're not wearing a seat belt and
you're in a car and you're [ __ ]
flying through windshields like you
could hurt other people too for sure but
it's not why that's a law yeah and then
added bonus is that you protect yourself
too sweet yeah also they see those are
super easy
right you know you're putting anyone at
inconvenience by yeah like therapy
nobody enjoys like not wearing a
seatbelt living of yeah this gets a
little scratched some people people
enjoy Julie like I don't know that was a
good example but like I still stand by
my argument I say my argument too
just something to think about like sweet
cap Real Housewives of Orange County
before we head to the airport yeah um I
called you last night after I finished
watching it because I'm completely down
to three 6180
on Bronwen like I was so here for her
but honestly her entire storyline is
like airing her dirty laundry and you
made the greatest point ever that like
now all I think about is like when
you're a new housewife like I don't give
a [ __ ] about you let alone like your
family drama that's like with Dallas you
didn't watch what I carry with her
husband like I just didn't care um so
Broadman and braun whitley constantly
coming for her mom like just trying to
like make it seem like her mom like I'd
have a stable G parent home like welcome
to America nobody [ __ ] does like we're
living on the street no you were living
with your grandparents in Laguna Beach
Brahman stop [ __ ] complaining okay and
your mom was [ __ ] doctor no she's
being out of control
I'm so not here for her like I think I I
don't like the way like her mom in hers
relationship on both ends is just weird
but then okay you have like a weird
tense relationship with your mom like
why are you bringing her and filming
every semen to dinner with all your new
friends are you just met and fighting in
front of them and it's like I your mom
seems like cool in certain respects cool
but like I'm not totally here for her
like I didn't sign up to watch
she's mom she's no mama Jean and she's
reminding me of Lydia's mom it's like
okay it's cool thing your mom's a free
spirit and like that's a fun fact about
you but like your mom isn't holding an
orange and your mom isn't your storyline
her every scene brought ones in her mom
is in and like while her mom is cool
looking it's I'm so uninterested your
mom isn't your storyline and throwing
your mom under the bus isn't the
storyline you know I don't know what
annoys me more seeing your mom or you
being mean to your mom you meet your mom
like honestly remember those friends who
just like talk back to their parents in
front of guests we acted like shake to
your chord like yeah since I was a child
I've always hated people who spoke
disrespectfully to their parents and
like when their parents I didn't like
discipline them I was like okay what
like there's literally a special place
in hell for people who yell at their
parents in front of company no totally
and like your mom wants the ring give
your mom the ring oh my god out of
control like that conversation was so
incredibly stupid like it's like it was
anything like if it was just such a
weird thing to like be so tense like if
I was wearing a ring that you gave me
and you loved it so much and you were
like can I wear
I can't hear ya no it was just so stupid
like so weird and I don't even give a
[ __ ] enough about Broadman still like
regular storyline to care about this
family drama and then the stuff with her
aunt like weird and like she came in so
strong and like for such a weak person
yeah that it's making me dislike if she
came in like the meek you know spineless
fool because she I would be like okay
like let's grow with you but you come in
you insult the ogia BOC like as if you
mean business and then it turns out
you're just like a spineless meek woman
and then you bring like thirsty like
going on and seeing Gretchen and Lizzie
like sorry that situation is weird and
honestly I'm not here for an shaming at
all and like the way she taught us a
hard case of ad shaming yeah and it's
like I'm an auntie like I know about the
auntie life and like we are just here
Dee and I and I mean I'm [ __ ] around
about the auntie's but no I want to know
what her aunt did if we're gonna be so
like dirty anti aunt and airing your
dirty laundry I want facts I want proof
she came to your school and embarrassed
you like house yeah I need to know
otherwise I'm like why are you
embarrassed by your family like right
that's your American here shitty yeah
yeah
I hate ya like unless she like showed up
drunk got arrested and I got a DUI you
know in the parent pick-up line yeah
what did she do that americium um also
the divide growing between Emily and
Jeana is one I find very interesting
like Emily is in such a bad place and
like so is Gina and neither one of them
have time to listen to each other and
they're both getting annoyed at each
other for like not being there for them
but it's like Emily literally can't be
there for anyone her [ __ ] family is in
shambles Gina almost got arrested in
front of her kids and she has no time
for nobody so I think they're both
starting to get annoyed with each other
like seeking companionship elsewhere and
then getting even more annoyed with each
other yeah but I understand like why
it's happening and I think that they'll
be fine but they both need like strong
support systems right now and they can't
be that for each other but at the very
least I did understand what Gina was
saying like when Emily was like my kiss
and it's like she can't of course I
can't even Drive how could she get to
the airport she would take an uber she's
sitting anywhere everywhere with her
kids like Gina's life is so fun he
doesn't have a license or a passport so
she actually couldn't go on a plane yeah
but I don't know how she's gonna go to
Arizona and also so Emily's doing the
dance but Shane's not coming now
so what's the point of doing the dance
for sex ourselves she say
I should be empowering but it's very sad
um and Ben was watching with me while
Emily and Shane were on screen and he
was like shook it's actually funny when
like you see like we're just used to
Shane now like that's just Shane but Ben
was like oh my god he's such a dick yeah
everything that comes out of his now and
Emily really nails like what's so
annoying about him which is really
shocking that they haven't been
separated yet it's like everything out
of his mouth of sarcastic and yeah yeah
he's never once been serious no in like
every pocket that they show us and like
I don't know if there's positive pockets
that we're missing but it's like even
when they give us a snippet like
everyone's mourning in the OC it's like
Shane's being an [ __ ] this morning
yeah it's so and by the way Shane now
has testimonials and his hair is like
dark he did something to his hair yeah
and it's like he's laughing with the
producers it's like they're boys in in
totally they they I'm she's very very
much here for Shannon beador just like
being her happiest and trying to make
peace but with everyone and I had a
thought
because member Tamara's here and she was
saying like I don't know why Vicki's I
mean I don't know why
Kelly hates me now because like you'll
see this whole season I'm totally on her
side and she is she keeps saying she
keeps making a point to say she doesn't
want to be on Vicki sided that she's on
Kelly's side and a part of me kind of
thought last night that Tamra like so
wholeheartedly took Kelly side not for
the reasons you might think but because
Vicki got demoted and it's like obvious
that like the audience is over Vicki
that's why the show demoted her and she
just like wants to be on the side of
America do you know any mean Oh proud I
think that is how the women think I
thought you were gonna say I think she's
on Kelly side maybe just because like
I'm on Kelly side too I get Vicki goes
below it's a pattern with Vicki whereas
Kelly was just reacting to what Vicki
does yeah but I thought she was gonna be
on Kelly side because I'm in the back of
her head like she feels guilty because I
don't know if she realizes but she
brought up the Train so now she has to
defend Kelly and by the way that's why
Kelly is mad at her yeah because it was
Tamara who brought it up once and then
explained it in the car that's a great
[ __ ] point so maybe like time and
camera keep saying like Vicki brought it
up thanke brought it up and maybe
subconsciously she knows that she did
and at the very least said she had a
part in making it a storyline so she's
now she wants to preemptively defend
Kelly interesting it didn't work no also
there's tons of Twitter drama between
Brandi Glanville and Tamra and
Brandi Glanville started this YouTube
show and she likes it she called Tamra
net and like Tamra went off and then she
went off and now they have a scheduled
appearance together in Orange County
next week and I'm really looking forward
to her what that's gonna be like because
they've been like saying evil things to
each other on Twitter Oh weird
unless Britney's rejoining real houses
in Beverly Hills wizzy which it does not
look like she is um not interest on time
there's something so sad about like a
housewife who is no longer on the show
but still remains like in the in the
conversation but yeah like Jill Zarin
yeah it's if she's never gonna be back
so I let's stop talking about it cuz
it's nowt sad but at least like Jill
Zarin doesn't have Twitter beef yeah
Jose arns better than that yeah and like
she's a new man
yeah a hot one a tennis pro okay we
gotta head to the airport but thank you
guys so much for being here to listen to
the morning to the Melania Morning Show
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so feel
free to subscribe to us on youtube
youtube.com slash morning toast also
feel free to give this video thumbs up
if you're a podcaster we're also
available as a podcast on Spotify iTunes
stitcher literally anywhere you can
listen to podcasts leave a review there
five stars about how beautiful we are
tickets available to the torat girl with
no job comm and we're gonna be recording
a patreon episode this week those scenes
it's gonna start right now
patreon.com/scishow morning toast $7.99
for extra five month episodes month I
think you'll really enjoy it everyone
has great things to say about it we love
you guys so much we will see you in
Austin see you in Austin new episode of
the snatchler is also up so check it out
you